yeah welcome I hope you're all slowly
resurfacing from your after lunch uh
energy dip now that you're all properly
caffeinated again
um I'm here to talk about practical code
archeology
and like all good things this talk
started out as a joke there was a
Twitter threat going on discussing uh
talks that people would would be willing
to submit to Norm komf another machine
learning focused conference that will be
in two weeks and someone posted as a
joke this uh title the title that I'm
presenting today figuring out what that
notebook from two years ago did
practical code archeology and I thought
wow this is a talk I would definitely
watch or visit if I would be attending
um but then the schedule was released
for normcunt and no one had contributed
this talk and I felt really sad so it
decided Well you know I'm just gonna try
and write it myself
and I think the reason that this talk
title resonated with me so much is that
I've seen code archeology or at least
whatever I pictured for that term I've
encountered it in every part of my
career so far so now I'm wondering who
of you in this room already secretly
feels a bit like a code archaeologist
who is familiar with this feeling of
digging around an old
frustrating code yeah definitely it's
more than half of the room so this this
was also my feeling I'm really great
that I'm today here with you because we
share this feeling so my career so far
I'm now a senior machine learning
engineer at Florine well Machine
learning engineers and data scientists
are digging around in Legacy code all
the time before that I worked as a
researcher at the University of twenty
and before that I worked as a computer
security specialist at the government
and in all these three roles there was
definitely digging around an old Legacy
code so from students from professors
that might have been retired even
tools that were created by colleagues in
their spare time and that suddenly ended
up in production
a code from our interns from one or two
or three years ago which is ancient
history at a machine learning startup
right so
um wherever you are and whatever role
you have when it relates to data or
software I think there is a code
archeology component to your work
so code archeology what do I mean by
that well just dealing with old stuff
skeletons in your company's closet or
maybe your own your side project that
get abandoned
um
dealing with anything ranging from
notebooks to maybe stack Overflow
Snippets that got copied over by one of
your colleagues in the past
databases that no one dares to touch
anymore
uh apis that are or are not maintained
code in the broad sense of the word
right another term for code archeology
is software archeology so I guess it's
all the same
it's really really really frustrating to
do that digging around in old
unmaintained or undocumented code so why
do we do this to ourselves
sometimes we would just want to know
okay I have this piece of code here when
did we last work on it who can I contact
if I want to know how I can expand on
this
um sometimes we get something from a
really questionable source so in my
security time that was malware for
example if you unpack malware I want to
see what it does that's also digging
around in code from which you don't know
the
um the origin
or
um
well I'm sure you can come up with
examples from your own line of work as
well
there is one advantage to that
frustration and that pain of code
archeology and that is that when you're
digging and when you're going through
all those frustrations
this teaches us how to be better
software Engineers so that's the that's
the Silver Lining I can tell you about
today you will encounter things maybe
you did it yourself in the past maybe it
was your interns or your colleagues
former colleagues that will make you go
oh God I will I never want to see this
again in my life so it will teach you
about maybe improving your software
engineering skills a bit
code archeology is super Broad and I
think that depending on the sector and
your experience and your background you
might have different approaches to it so
I only have 30 minutes to talk about all
the stuff that I like about code
archeology but I have three main points
that I would like to give to you
um the first one is we're probably all
technology focused people and we just
love the next shiny big thing in
technology land right and
I'm here to tell you that most of the
code archeology
things that I've done were always solved
way more easily by just talking to
people going out there hunting down the
people responsible
um or just trying to work together
instead of throwing more and more shiny
tools at it
secondly we don't only love technology
as technology Savvy people we also love
complexity
but complexity adds more confusion to
the mix so I am here to ask you please
always start with the simplest tool or
simplest solution that you know
and the third point is sometimes the
really simple steps don't work or
talking doesn't get you anywhere for
example the person responsible for the
code has left there's nothing you can do
you have to work with whatever skills
and Common Sense and
tenacity you have
at that moment in time just try to use
everything that you have and know and
use whatever detective skills you have
and to use them we must first develop
them so
take the time in your work schedule or
in your study schedule or personal
development time to get some detective
skills under your belt because it might
not seem immediately relevant but it
will definitely save you time in the
long run
now if you have no clue as to where you
could start with developing some what I
call detective skills anything written
by Julia Evans is a really good place to
start so this is an abstract of one of
my favorite Comics by Julia Evans which
is called how to be a wizard programmer
the too long didn't read is just ask the
good questions and dare to ask those
questions because it's perfectly fine
not to know anything the only thing you
could do is take it one step towards the
solution
if we're going to talk about code
archeology of course we have this group
of people that have been working on
dealing with old dusty stuff for a few
hundred years more than we have done as
software Engineers or data scientists or
whatever you call yourself and that's of
course a real world archaeologists
and the thing that they do that I really
like in which I think we should learn
from them is that we should study the
culture
from which artifacts come
so in our case the artifacts in question
are pieces of code for example and the
culture is the person or the group of
people that has made this thing
and that have left traces
or information in that artifact that
you're studying so I would like to turn
now to Indiana Jones he might not be
recognizable without his hat but this is
actually Indiana Jones Harrison Ford
um he tells his classroom at some points
that 70 percent of archeology is done in
the library and I would like to badly
paraphrase this by saying that 70 of
good code archeology is done just by
talking to people
so go out there and collect all the
stories that you can find for example at
your workplace
and I brought a few examples that I
encountered in my career so far so for
example if you encounter a list of
product names somewhere in a database in
your company and it turned out they're
all really handily coded by alphabetical
letters
and there's one missing
what do you do you go to your CTO or CEO
or most senior colleague or maybe the
person that worked there longest and you
say
what happened to be where is B I need to
know
it turned out that there was definitely
a story behind this so apparently the
company where I encountered this used to
have a product called B
and it was really popular and it was
really really profitable
but it was really bad for the client and
once the company found out they designed
it like this but by accident once the
company found out he immediately moved
everyone over to the subsequent product
which was C and they completely erased
or tried to erase B from all production
but of course if you start digging into
Legacy code at that company you will
find remnants of B
and at that moment it's really handy to
know what the story behind that is
another example imagine looking at the
code that is run in production at a car
dealership
and you find out that the most important
class in all their models and all their
production code is called bike
that's really illogical so what's the
story behind this and again you go to
the person that works their longest and
say
what's this bike thing I keep seeing
everywhere it's in every database query
that we make and it's in every dashboard
that we have but we sell cars
what's up with that please explain it to
me
and it might turn out that this car
dealership but some
long ago Moment In Time started out
selling bikes but had to Pivot for you
know business reasons but at that point
in time all of their production code all
their inventory information for example
already used this name and it would be
too expensive for time consuming or not
handy to rename everything that you have
in production and that's where this bike
thing comes from
and then the last one
same goes for table names you might have
multiple tables in your data warehouse
or data lake or whatever
all with slightly different but very
similar sounding names now imagine your
your boss tells you to you know just run
an analysis on light and license data
for me please I need it tomorrow
and you have these five different tables
that you can just pull things out of and
they all kind of look the same
what do you do well you'll have to Fair
it out what the differences are and
where they like are where they are
critically different
um the company where I got this example
from they had multiple sources of data
so they had their internal data they had
data from one or two data suppliers they
had data from a government or oversight
committee and all these parties use the
same word for slightly different things
so it turned out that these tables were
not the same at all this was just how
the supplier gave them the data and they
never bothered to rename it
foreign
I was asking my colleagues how they do
code archeology and one of my colleagues
said what I think is the best summary of
how I like to approach code archeology
too and that's like this she said well
I do get blame get blame get blame and
then I slack someone
and I think that's that's really the
core of what I want to talk about
um it's just that you know when you're
using get blame
it's not necessarily fun to read right
you you get this entire file annotated
with who contributed what line and when
the fun thing is that of course we have
other browsers for
going through commits so the thing that
I like to use is Tig
which is just a regular commit browser
it's much more user friendly if you ask
me so you can use it on a repository so
sorry no live coding
and it will show you all the commits and
also merge commits denoted with an M you
can see the different branches and how
they relate to each other
um you can open up a commit and inspect
it
but how I use it for code archeology is
you can instead call it on a specific
file and it will give you the entire
history of that file with the names of
whoever contributed and when
so this is much easier on the eyes than
you know the git lock output that I know
a lot of people use of course you can
also just install plugins in your IDE if
that's your jam that's fine too I only
started using an IDE six months ago so
don't don't know anything about that
there's also a cool thing that we can
learn from archaeologists I found out by
accident
um archaeologists use stratigraphy which
is dating objects based on the layer of
soil they were found in
so with this something that is found in
a high soil layer is younger than an
object found in a lower soil layer which
is logical right because history just
adds layers of soil to the Earth and if
you dig deeper and deeper you will find
older and older things
the fun thing is I love this color chart
we can do something similar for our git
blame output to make it more easily
readable
it turns out
the default color settings for gibblame
color by HR not that useful so I believe
it does something like color everything
that's newer than 12 weeks ago whites
then everything that's younger than one
year ago blue and then
everything that's older than that
is all the same
however I wrote this beautiful one-liner
which I will now explain basically we
add a rainbow I'm a big fan of rainbows
that color codes every line of Code by
year and of course if you have a
different use case or you work in very
short project cycles and you want to see
one color per project for example you
can also do that because this is all
customized
so in the first bit of the one liner we
say we're just gonna change the
configuration of this git repository
don't touch anything else on my system
so I recommend that if you're trying to
get config things out right
in the second part we add a custom color
scheme and the third part is the custom
color scheme so we start at the one end
of the rainbow red six years ago and we
end it at magenta
for one year ago and the rest is just
white so white is recent
and then you can make a beautiful layer
cake like this which is very close to
the stratigraphy illustration that I
showed you earlier
this is just for fun but you can
immediately see that it's immediately
easier on the eyes you can definitely
see the different blocks of code that
correspond to different moments in time
so other neat command line tools I'm a
big fan of the Linux command line so if
I have a problem I will always start
with well tools like this I would like
to encourage you to pick whatever tool
you like to use and read demand page try
I I'm pretty sure you will find a
command line flag that you did not yet
know about that might come in handy
somewhere in the future like the color
by age git blamed it for me
of course
all the tips that I gave so far they
kind of apply only to code that is under
Version Control right because if it's
not Version Control we can't get blame
anyone
and as python slash data enthusiasts I
think a lot of us work with notebooks
of course you can put notebooks under
Version Control but since every cell
execution will be embedded as metadata
in that notebook putting it in a
repository is very tedious I don't think
most people do that
so what are our options if it's just you
know freestyle no versioning code
I was talking earlier about that I would
like to encourage people to just use the
simplest approach they can take
and this is something that a lot of
people then say they will do right just
run the code
see what happens
as a former computer security person I
would like to ask you
please please please don't
at least read it first
just the other day I was working with
some game files I have done some video
games research in the past and I love
tinkering with those in my spare time
and I found a very neat script on GitHub
that told me well you know I can unpack
all the game files that you want those
are often in proprietary formats by game
publishers
um just run it just point this thing at
your steam directory and it will do
magic things for you
turns out it overwrote game files in the
steam directory it didn't ask the user I
mean the the script looked fine it had
documentation it had very usable
uh terminal arguments that you can use
it looked like a very polished piece of
software but if you opened it up and
read it
it turned out that it was just
overwriting all your save files and
destroying everything that wasn't a game
directory that's very painful
reading code is of course a
ah
I was afraid that was my 30 minute timer
but it's not so no problem no problem
great
um reading code is a skill right that we
all need to develop
and some people really don't like it
especially if it gets to more than 100
lines of code for example
but the cool thing is one with practice
it does get better and I think that the
people of you who have contributed to
open source code for example will know
that once you get more and more exposure
to other people's code
it improves and it improves fast so I
would say it's worth the time investment
and also what I really like is that the
stuff we learned in high school about
reading non-fiction texts
is applicable to code you just have to
kind of transform that knowledge and
make it applicable to code but it is the
same so in high school they teach you
try to answer the basic questions first
who what when and why and especially for
The Who
I like to keep this mental profile of
all the people that I know at a company
and try to pattern match their coding
Style
to the code that you see I think you all
have a colleague that codes in a
specific way and that if you see code
written by this person you go
it was you well you can use that
knowledge once you're if you're digging
down in company code right
the other thing is that they teach you
in high school that if you're reading a
non-fiction text and you have to answer
questions about it you have to focus on
the most important parts of the text so
for non-fiction that's things like
headings you look at images or graphs
you look at captions maybe look at
keywords or blurbs that jump out of you
jump out at you from the text
and with code it's just the same right
so there's a priority list you can go
through
um and start with the most important
points so I like to focus on the inputs
and output especially since the example
that I told you about happened
um and things like dependencies code
structure class names logging so you can
use this slide as a checklist I would
say to get to the most important points
of the code first and to really
understand what it does and answer the
questions that I just showed you
if you have to read a large piece of
code another thing that I can really
recommend is fair on it so I didn't
really know much about programming
before I went to work at Floren but
there's a really good guide by Tuple
which is a company that has written a
guide about prep programming
and I'm a convert I always used to think
of pair programming is doing the work of
one person with two people so it's less
efficient and costs double the time no
give it a spin it is actually much
faster and it's also more fun if you're
trying to figure out what a piece of
code does and you can work together like
a detective Duo it's much more efficient
and it's way nicer
when all else feels or the the reading
the code does not give you the
information that you're looking for or
you really need to type in deeper deeper
of course you can run the code
um you can add comments for example to
make it all a bit more clear for
yourself what the code is doing you can
add some logging you can try to come up
with some
mock-up inputs so it doesn't destroy
important files
and I would recommend that you try to
keep your development environment as
clean and safe as possible so use not
just virtual environments and Pi EnV
just to get it working
consider using Docker containers or
virtual machine or run it on an air gap
computer for example depending on you
know your line of work and how dangerous
the coding question is
just make sure it doesn't mess up your
production
now to wrap things up I promised in the
abstract of this talk to answer the
question do I need to bring my hat for
code archeology
um
code archeology is an activity that we
pursue indoors so I would say no
instead bring some comfy clothing your
favorite caffeinated beverage of choice
and a toolkit
the simpler the tools the better
and a good dose of
grits tenacity and quite some patience
because I think that's what you need
most for code archeology
thank you
foreign
I'll be happy to take any questions
thanks Judith for this presentation uh
no worries no worries I wanted to say
thank you just uh and thank you for
digging up these useful tools I find
them useful and uh you promised memes we
got some memes yes I like them so I
learned from the best questions it was
you first right
so thanks for the talk I felt very
identified with your thoughts uh one of
the things you said is that the the more
cover the followers and actually you do
the more you can learn to write things
properly I fully agree so do you now
write more comments or write more
explicit codes
um I would say but that's also thanks to
my colleagues because I'm an you know ex
academic uh and the code I used to write
was horrible and now it's slightly less
horrible
um mostly because of the mentorship of
my colleagues uh I think the thing that
changed most is my coach structure so
writing into more object-oriented way so
that you can from just reading it
immediately see how it's supposed to be
used and in what context
does that answer your question
oh yes good
any other questions
just to continue on that they also write
more unit tests now
yeah well you know I'm working in an
industry company now so yeah we we test
a lot because it's production and it
shouldn't break uh academics generally
don't write tests
I'm sorry
if you want a very nice place to start
by the way of learning more Linux
command line tools Julia Evans also has
a list of the command line tools that
she uses most of the time which is I
think there's about 30 of them that's a
really cool place to start so depending
on what you do most often you can pick
one or two so for the network oriented
people net stopped or TCP dump for
example
um for the people that work a lot with
data or texts I would say find and grep
uh grep is really my favorite in that
sense but I used to be an NLP so
anything with regular Expressions Is My
Jam
yeah since no no there are no other
questions I will just ask
do you have any ideas about data
archeology if you have a bunch of Excel
files PDFs oh yeah there's a lot to be
said about that maybe I should give it
follow-up talk next year about that so I
used to work in digital forensics uh so
that means that whenever a computer
crime or a computer security incident
has happened you go in and you try to
extract as much information from
whatever happened
as possible and it would Amaze you how
much metadata is hidden in in files and
in operating systems that you can
forcefully pull out of there if you know
what tools to use and what what keywords
to to Google
um so for example notebooks they save
all this metadata about the cells that
have been executed and in which order
and maybe even by whom there is so much
information you can extract like a
complete timeline from a notebook if you
know how to I believe there's open
source packages for that so
pretty cool
anymore
um so a comment and a question yeah the
comment first is what you said about
notebooks being very hard to put in get
the way we sort of solve that is that we
have CI clear the notebooks before
they're checked in and then save the
HTML which contains all the history
separately so then if you have your
notebooks and Git You can actually see
useful diffs of them in merge requests
and stuff that sounds really useful yeah
so that's that's a nice tips uh yeah we
have a snippet somewhere for that if
people need it and then my question is
um I think as programmers we're always
quite afraid to delete things like we
think you know we may need this later or
something I know earlier this week Tom
and I were working we had to you know
work on some old notebook but there were
actually two notebooks that looked like
the first half was the same and then the
second half was different and it was
like okay obviously one of these was
first but they were checking at the same
time yeah and they were both players so
we didn't know when they were executed
so like which one is the one I need so
maybe do you have thoughts on like best
practices for when you Fork something
and it's like this is the one I want but
I don't want to delete this because
maybe someone will need this later and
then a year later you come back and
you're like wait which one of these is
actually the thing yeah I think in my
company I kind of see two
um
styles of working in that sense
um so as a former academic and maybe
code archaeologist I tend to not delete
anything ever which sometimes is a
problem my tech lead on the other hand
has started complimenting people for
deleting as much lines of code as
possible so there's the information
hoarders versus the let's iterate fast
and change things
I would in this case make a third
notebook probably and try to it depends
on what you want to do right if you're
just investigating or whether you want
to rerun it again
[Music]
um
if you're just investigating you can use
the open source package for extracting
metadata that I mentioned earlier and
maybe find out which notebook was
executed latest because it will tell you
something about the timeline of both the
notebooks and maybe you can work from
there
um if you just want to run it
I don't know read the code and try to
make like a third Fork version of both
the notebooks and keep the best parts
that really depends on your use case
I meant more like at the time of doing
that you know maybe it would have been
good to label it or something
naming add more documentation that's the
pain I was talking about once you've
once you've gone through a project like
this I will shut up now once you've gone
through a project like this next time
you will think oh yeah we had those two
notebooks this was made by this and this
person on this and this date for this
and this purpose and you never have the
problem again
I hope
you're watching okay
last question uh or another question is
uh well why not just delete it because
it's in git anyway yeah
that's also a possibility it really
depends on how essential it is
we worked on it for a year and now it's
gone we don't have to look at it again
it's a failed attempt
I'm not sure that qualifies as a
question though this is a good joke do
you wanna yeah
what if someone changes the git history
depends on whether you know your Tech
Team allows Force pushing
what if it happened you know how do you
do oculine
well then you can always do the
non-version control code uh uh
techniques right you just have to use
more of your uh detective skills
one final Applause
foreign